tom varducci knew about this even though
tom was working on the diamondbacks and
the dodgers telecast yesterday tom on
loan from mlbd network joining us there
pretty impressive performance from a
detroit tiger pitcher there tyler
alexander
yeah it is i mean listen this is an
interesting season we're seeing all
kinds of i think weird records and
schedules and
anything goes we knew that going in but
i guess if you wanted to skip to the
shorthand
dan you would say let's just have the
yankees play the dodgers tomorrow yeah
let's go straight to the world series
and forget about this other nonsense and
weirdness
if not those two then who
uh really good question you know the
braves to me are an underrated team i
mean they won what 97 games last year
and they're kind of an experienced
younger team now i think they're a
little bit dangerous
you know the american league the
minnesota twins are just picking up
where they left off last year we've seen
them though in the postseason just can't
get by the new york yankees but
there's like a a tier of near elite
players but i gotta say the yankees and
the reds
and the and the dodgers are in their own
tier above
that elite tier also with what i i
watched clayton kershaw yesterday
because i was kind of holding my breath
after getting scratched opening day
that's as good as he's looked in three
years i'm gonna guess tom
there's no doubt about that dan listen
he went to driveline the high-tech
facility in washington
to try to recapture some of his fastball
velocity and he has
i mean he hit 93 a little over 93
yesterday that's
that was his best fastball in at least
two years since july of 2018
and i think even better than that then
he was just the ball was coming
out of his hand easy his command was
impeccable
i was surprised that he went back out
for the sixth inning
uh he clearly talked to the manager dave
roberts and said hey i'm good that was a
really good sign he held his stuff
through that game
um yeah if you're a dodger and watching
him pitch he i don't know if he noticed
this dan
he worked so quickly he worked twice as
fast as he normally does
i think that's just an indication of how
good he felt these postponements over
the weekend
i i'd liken baseball to being on a high
wire with no net right now
it just feels like the commissioner is
holding his collect their baseball's
holding their collective breath
can the commissioner exhale anytime soon
with this situation right now
no i don't think so because listen we
know that
this season for the owners anyway is
mostly about the postseason right
there's a billion dollar pot of gold at
the end of the post
season for the owners from tv money more
than 60 of national tv money comes into
postseason so they need to get
not just to the end of the regular
season but really to the end of the
postseason this is what this season is
about
and i think what happened first with the
marlins now at the cardinals has been
a wake-up call i think for the most part
then players have been really good
about sticking to the protocols but
these were cases that proved
just stepping out of line a little bit
jeopardizes everybody and when i say
everybody i'm talking about the entire
league not just one team
so you can't get together with your
buddies after a game and have a pizza
which is what's going on you know you
can't go back to the same behavior that
you had before
and i think a lot of teams i know the
dodgers had a team meeting about this
the diamondbacks did as well
we got to be better guys you know
there's no room to
just let your guard down and i i think
as i said players on the hall have done
a really good job but that was a wake-up
call that
it has to be even better does baseball
punish the marlins
franchise are these players
you know i don't think so they're doing
their own investigation then to get to
the bottom of this i think they already
know
in a general sense you know what was
happening where the breach came
the good news for baseball dan is nobody
believes at least in baseball
that the act of playing baseball outside
leads to transmission of the disease
right the phillies played the marlins
when a bunch of their players were
positive and all week long no philly
player
tested positive i think that was the
underlying silver lining in this case
is that it's mostly about what are you
doing away from the field of play
that brings us to our final story joanna
cespedes
and can can you explain in
30 seconds to us what happened yesterday
with
the meds outfitter well there was a
period there where the mets were clearly
concerned because he wasn't at the
ballpark and nobody had heard from him
since the previous day they actually
sent security people to his room at the
hotel
they opened the door there's no
suspicious there's no personal
belongings he's clearly
not there and gone but they still don't
know where he is it wasn't until during
the game that his agent called up and
said oh by the way
he's got home he's not going to play for
the rest of the year so
you know bottom line is good thing that
he's safe i respect as
as the meds do anybody's decision if
they don't want to play
in this atmosphere right lorenzo came to
the brewers did so
the other day but you know what he told
the team what he was doing
he didn't get up and leave without
telling anybody
that was the irresponsible part the
decision to opt out
i get it you know it's going to happen
we're going to see some more dan
especially when it comes
to older players who have the security
of money
and or position on a team yeah but let's
talk about maybe an underlying theme
here that he wasn't going to reach
incentive levels he didn't like
he was complaining about his playing
time a little bit i understand the
health part of this
but i think this is the part of the
healthy bank account that was bothering
him more than his own health
no question that was one of my concerns
going into the season that
you're playing amid a pandemic there's
some risk involved let's face it
there's nobody in the stands your
paycheck is a fraction of what it
normally would be
what keeps you going what keeps you
going is the chance to play in the
postseason and maybe some personal
records or we hope personal pride
but i think if you're not playing well
and your team's not playing well and you
have that security
i expect we're going to see a few more
guys not giant waves of people but a few
more guys say you know what why am i
here
i'm just going to go home not so much
count my money but make sure i stay safe
and secure
i wonder if the mets tried to embarrass
him by
filing a missing persons report tom
like i think that isn't his agent
his former agent the gm of the meds yeah
like i don't know it felt like they
tried to emba
sespedis was embarrassing the mets it
felt like the mets might have sent a
volley back to say oh we're going to
file a missing person's report here
it's i don't know i think understandable
to read it that way i do listen they put
out the statement that he wasn't there
and they had no idea where he was
without really any sense of his
well-being now
you can praise them for being
transparent for a guy showing up
not at the ballpark and telling the
media that he wasn't there they didn't
have to do that
but i guess if you're a little bit of a
cynic
you would say there was a motivation
behind that than just transparency
was somebody taking a shower or are they
at the sink there
tom that i'm in my basement
studio as if i have another studio
and i think that's something to do with
the uh irrigation system running oh okay
i i
thought i thought somebody uh was
was uh taking a shower there wonderful
world of plumbing
the audible sound of plumbing music's in
my ears
oh thanks for joining us as always tom
we appreciate your time
yeah any time thank you tom verducci mlb
network analyst he was on the call
dodgers in the diamondback